بعد جدل زياره رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
السابق نانسيبي لوسي الى تايوان برز الى
الواجهه حديث عن المجال الجوي وتحديدا ما
يعرف بالخط الاوسط ومنطقه تحديد الدفاع
الجوي بين تايوان والصين فاذا كان لكل
دوله مجال جوي مدني تتحكم فيه بالطائرات
المدنيه التي تدخله ويعبر عنه بالمجال
الجوي المدني فلهذه الدول ما يعرف بمنطقه
تحديد الدفاع الجوي وتكون اكبر من المجال
الجوي المدني وتتيح الفرصه للدوله للتعرف
على اي طيران حربي يقترب من حدودها الصين
اعلنت حضره طيران شمل طيران في وقت قالت
فيه وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه انها تعقبت
35 طائره عسكريه صينيه في محيط الجزيره
منطقه حظر طيران التي تتحدث عنها بيجين
تقع على بعد 85 ميلا بحريا شمل تايوان اين
نحو 157 كيلومترا والاغلاق وفق تايباي
سيكون ضمن منطقه تحديد الدفاع الجوي
للجزيره سيؤثر ذلك فيما بين 60 و70% من
الرحلات الجويه بين الشمال شرق اسيا وجنوب
شرق اسيا وكذلك الرحلات الجويه بين تايوان
وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان وامريكا
الشماليه في 2021 سجل التايوان نحو الف
عمليه التوغل لطائره حربيه صينيه في الجهه
الجنوبيه الغربيه لمنطقه تحديد الدفاع
الجوي وهو اكثر من ضعف ما سجل في 2020
الجدل القائم سلطه الضوء ايضا على ما يعرف
بالخط الاوسط وهو حدود غير رسميه وضعت
خلال الحرب البارده يلتزم بها الى حد كبير
وتمتد على طول منتصف المضيق الفاصل بين
تايوان والصين على مدى العامين الماضيين
اعلن المسؤولون الصينيون ان الخط الاوسط
من وجهه نظرهم غير موجود وسجل كمثال تجاوز
للخط من طائره وسفن حربيه صينيه خلال
مناورات عسكريه في اغسطس من العام الماضي
معركه الحدود الجويه تاتي بينما اشارت
اوبيسي غروب وهي شركه متخصصه في مجال
النقل الجوي ومخاطر الطيران الى ان قيودا
سابقه على الطيران ادت الى اضطرابات كبيره
في الرحله الجويه بالمنطقه واضطرت بعض
الطيارين الى حمل وقود اضافي